it's at that time I only had one front
tooth when I was 10 years old this is
really stupid I know but when I was 10
years old I was playing in a football
game rugby rugby league actually and I
tackled this big fat kid right around
the ankles smack went down like a sack
of [__] fatty thanks for coming cuz I'm
getting up from the tackle if Anna can
just kicks me in the face
guess what he wasn't used to being
tackled obviously just turned around
just went boom
straighten the folks kicked my tooth out
and I just had this like strange thing
where I never got a fixed used to drive
my poor mother crazy like just please
get your tooth fixed but I was like
Vanna you know my life summers happened
to me weirdest cars and as bad as of
Honor in my life
she's like you know a Java nuts you know
it took until I was seriously right and
I was working as an actor right was
doing state work I was doing team that
you work with one tooth and now I worked
for a guy called George Ogilvie and he
cast me as the lead in his movie and he
sat down he was talking to me said dumb
so tell me the story about the tooth so
I went through the thing football camp
our blog you know I'm being authentic
and all that sort of stuff expound see
cuz here's we have a problem because in
my movie the character of Johnny the one
you're playing he has two front teeth
hey let me to get a tooth after you know
himself not from the production budget
and the funniest thing is man and I know
you're gonna find this quite obvious now
that I say it to you but you know I did
a hundred film auditions and never got a
film I got my tooth fixed whoa
very much but at the same time there is
a kind of intimidating thing of like oh
that's on you that's not on me what's
coming from you did you see that
terrible Kylie wax when I showed in the
monologue this is so bad I mean it's
really